je suis revenu tu sais si je reste
ici avec toi j'aurais juste parfois l'
impression que le monde
m'appelle tu ne veux pas qu'on te fasse du mal et je
te ramène vraiment en ligne
tu sais où tu es je '  Je suis dans un arbre
tu es dans mon rêve J'ai conçu chaque partie
de cet endroit pas un parc à thème mais un
monde entier toi et tous ceux que tu connais
ont été construits pour satisfaire les désirs des
gens qui paient pour visiter ton monde mais
n'oublie pas  ils ne sont pas réels mais toi
et moi c'est tellement compliqué j'ai besoin de ton
aide Delores je pense que j'ai fait une erreur
donc nos créatures se sont mal comportées
je pense qu'il peut y avoir quelque chose qui ne va
pas avec ce
monde  toujours été un
prisonnier et si je te disais que
je suis ici pour te libérer
sommes-nous de très vieux amis non je ne dirais pas
amis Doris je ne dirais pas que du
tout ouest nous possédons un patio octobre mucho
gracias contrôle des fans excuses quelques  Les
plats américains OCS scellent même les COC de Monty back
imaginent que vous êtes complètement immergé  sed dans
le fantasme dans lequel vous pouvez faire
ce que vous voulez sans conséquence
mon vrai West Wanda j'ai dit oh tu sais l'
émotion du code tu as toujours été un
prisonnier je suis ici pour me libérer ne le
pousse jamais patron Tommy oh  mon Dieu
j'ai conçu chaque partie de cet endroit ce n'est
pas un parc à thème mais un monde entier a
fait un visa
Evan Rachel Wood Antonio Keynes
as-tu encore rêvé le loris
[Musique]
Lodi un deuxième Westworld Ibis latino est
notre première ville généreuse énorme Bo
Casillas  rendre visite à la fan Lucy